bien alors olivier de kersauson vous
êtes l'idole de mon neveu
fabrice qui rêvent de vous rencontrer
et quand je lui ai dit que je vous
recevrai ici ce soir
il m'a demandé de vous poser quelques
questions en plus le pauvre il sait pas
que vous aimez pas qu'on vous appelle à
meyrals voici l'interview dit amiral
alors d'utah miral pourquoi sur un
bateau en deep à droite et gauche mais
tribord aube à bord
fall est en tournée en france culture
alors prêt pas prêt service public
préparez vos oreillers
on dit tribord parce que c'est le côté
ou quand gouvernait avec un aviron setis
tir de l'anglais ce tir ou du des
langues nordiques se dire qui veut dire
gouverner c'est est adroit à droite
c'était toujours à droite du navire ce
cas est là qui est mieux tribord
d'accord et bâbord je sais pas d'où
c'est venu voilà c'est pas une réponse
c'est pas france culture
parce que je pense que si l'origine en
france culture les arts à trouver une
explication à la mes couilles dit amiral
c'est froid quand on tombe à l'eau
jamais jamais arrivé je n'ai pas envie
que ça m'a franchement amiral c'est pas
un peu chiant de faire le tour du monde
en bateau
bah non non les vallées longueur des
fois ne vous rendez pas compte
vous faites météorologiquement et
géographiquement un parcours unique et
complet avec vous allez partir avec des
vents d'ouest récupérer du nord du
nord-est long des côtes d'afrique vous
aller couper l'équateur m'avait dit
parfois des calmes vous allez après
longer les côtes du brésil descendre
dans les quarantièmes rugissants voie
des mers énorme les vents formidable des
iceberg remontée de l'autre côté du cap
horn c'est quand même la plus belle
occupation plus avoir un chante le masne
on vous plaît en tout les cas oui
dites-moi amiral quand on voit que rémy
bricka la traversée en ski gonflables la
traversée de l'atlantique c'est pas un
peu surestimé non c'est je pense ça n'a
pas été très compliqué pour rémy bricka
mais c'est l'atlantique sud un seul et
du cap vert à
il est assez gonflé d'ailleurs ce que
même si cet océan parfois pesé assez
violent dit amiral c'est vrai que quand
vous êtes hacker vous avez un déodorant
qui sent le poisson tu dira t'on r2 il
est marrant ce ne veut quand même dit
amiral vous êtes plutôt à voile ou à
vapeur uniquement
dites-moi amiral vous pensez qu on vous
connaît plus parce que vous êtes marins
ou parce que vous êtes marrant je ne
sais pas je m'en fout d'ailleurs moyens
ce qui m'intéresse ce que je connais moi
ouais deux mois ouais ça vous trouve
charmant bébé un passé là elle est
terrible elle ne venait ici ceux du chum
la moquette la wii dit amiral vous avez
des nouvelles de tabarly parce que son
tour du monde ça dure un peu quand même
nom n'est pas non mais c'est quelqu'un
qui je pense a tellement apporté hausse
n'était à ce métier et 7e art est
immense personnage tellement
exceptionnel et humainement nous aussi
d'ailleurs ce que
non je c'est quelqu'un que moi enfin de
toute façon auquel je pense souvent
quand je suis en mer j'étais son second
pendant huit ans et c'est quelqu'un pour
jusqu'à j'avais et beaucoup de restait
beaucoup d'affection sûrement olivier
kasso jean départ en janvier
si tout va bien nous battre le record du
trophée jules verne